okay it says we're going live oh my god
that was the quickest going live I have
ever experienced with YouTube that joins
the being one of only two people I know
this is crazy this is intense so hello
everybody and welcome to round table
with the stream team this is where we
get to speak to constant creators about
you know their adventures and what they
ended up doing to make them become
content creators tonight we have mr.
anchorman v2 or as everyone else calls
them anchorman the lover of fallout 76
we're just gonna start calling you
addicts from now on because I he does
but yeah I don't plan on ripping on you
too much about 76 but I will I will do a
couple of jabs just like I expect you
with division so it's totally fine so
the rest of the guys are actually there
they're not able to make it today uh
mister MJ's a boss as per usual is stuck
with schoolwork unfortunately l-boogie
is down sick because you know that's
what always happens when around this
time probably Thanksgiving seeing family
sick kids you know how it goes and old
school he cannot do Thursday at
Tuesday's because he's East stuck at
work but so just wanted to you know make
sure you guys knew this so like I said
this is anchorman uh hello salty I hate
the blue how's it going on guys in chat
anchorman why don't you uh I want you go
ahead and uh I appreciate you coming and
you know just doing these one-on-ones
with me at least and so tell everybody
how did you become a concert creator why
did you want to do this I will say this
like I was bored you were bored so I got
started doing youtube back in 2013 my
first video was a first impressions
video on battlefield 4 using the Xbox
studio where they called already I
stopped using it upload studio
I used upload studio to make my first
video and
because I remember I got kind of
provoked into doing it because I was in
college I was a see I was a sophomore in
college I went to UNC Asheville and I
remember I was watching the play station
tree at see the trailer at the Super
Bowl and then I watched the watch their
event and then I watched Xbox do theirs
but I had jiggery duty that day so I
remember cuz it was just such a weird
situation and so I didn't get to watch
it until much later but I had all the
notes as they were coming out oh my gosh
what's going on here what's going on
here and I watched it later and I
watched it I was like oh I'm interested
in what Xbox was doing back in 2013 and
I saw a lot of people hating on if I
wasn't like really on social media like
that until later like I think I didn't
watch YouTube at all like I did I ever
do anything for YouTube was like
watching a couple like I go Potter
Puppet Pals and just stupid little
youtube news and I remember going
through that whole process and sanely I
can't believe people don't like the Xbox
one that much and I said a hard time
reconciling that and so I started like
hanging out with some of the other other
Xbox YouTube people a little bit I was
always kind of kept at arm's distance
was just fine I don't really care I met
some cool people on Facebook who were
going through their whole spiel and we I
started I started my youtube channel as
the anchorman v and I was what did the
few Xbox pro Xbox people but I was
shooting for like kind of like this
weird tone where it was more kind of
like a little snarky but like
informative and keeping video short
mm-hmm I was always like five minutes no
more than five minutes it takes me over
five minutes not without a video worth
making yeah so you kind of like what
went into that thought process of hey
I'm gonna I'm gonna make some videos but
I'm just gonna use short sweet to the
point
you know as gritty as possible no BS
just going right like right for it it
was all really straightforward stuff I
wanted to make sure it was like put it
in layman's terms like what do people
what do people actually care about
like I remember made of what a video
about when it came to the earnings
reports yeah I I took I came out I cook
I went out I took mics in college and so
I was like I was talking about the
earnings reports you know we get out the
end of the financial year what starts
posting all their earnings that kind of
stuff I remember looking at it and I
remember thinking about like okay
remember they showed off I came with the
the revenue was treks box I was like
someone's gonna look at this revenue
thing from Microsoft it'd be like oh man
they could buy all of Sony based on the
revenue I'm like some idiot is gonna
think this is exactly how much money
they actually made and not realize this
it's not profit right and someone's
gonna make a video claiming that they're
this is gonna be it so I made a video
and I said look anybody who says this
don't believe them they don't know the
difference between revenue and profit
big difference
well behold a certain youtuber whose
name starts with C came out saying Xbox
could buy PlayStation and Sony with this
money yeah I was like oh boy I was not
well-liked after that though it was
funny because like I had my terrible
college internet and could not make sure
it went out in time and so I was
literally watching it upload and the
videos uploading and while that happens
that video comes out and I watch I'm
like oh no so so I mean what like what
year did you graduate college on so
people have a time frame so I went to
college in 2011 fall 2011 actually
that's what do you love it
my love for fallouts an entirely
different story I really want to hear
that story but continue continue with
school I was in there I was doing four
years originally and then after three
years on a up I was it's a really dumb
story again I got um
when I was trying to get I was trying to
come back early and Ida like apply to go
back to my dorm room early and I got
well my roommate got approved and I got
denied and their reasoning was well
there's no one's gonna be on campus I
was like what my roommates gonna be on
campus in the same room and she's like
well if you don't like it you can leave
I said fine so on and on on that thing I
said I'm quitting and I applied to my
gopher College and I actually got
approved and I got a full ride to switch
and so literally by the end of spring
break I said hey look you told me to
leave I did that was back when I was
kind of an [ __ ] but yes I took an
extra year did two years ago for college
for two years and it was good
I really appreciated it I ended up doing
philosophy Poli Sci and then picked up a
minor business law okay so so I was
still doing YouTube during the entire
time right and that's where kind of
things picked up a lot faster so that
was about that was 2015 and and now and
now what do you do now I actually work
downtown at my local city I do nothing
in my field period as per what happens
when you graduate college yes I worked
in medical debt for a long time yeah so
that's my specialty so if you got
medical debt let me know I help you out
everyone everyone hears that well we'll
put a hash tag when this goes on say
hashtag medical debt for you as text
impacts
after all this impact for all yeah I
that this kind what I do now but so
during the whole time going back to the
whole YouTube thing I was messing around
on YouTube and I realized about but
after a year of doing YouTube that me
being a hardcore pro Xbox guy was boring
mm-hmm and not just that but like all of
a sudden like yeah I had a I had accrued
a pretty I would say pretty large but
I'll have about 4,000 subscribers and I
had pretty good regular views and I got
you know I had people coming at me all
the time which was I guess is a sign of
success yeah at least enough so that's
how I met actually a lot of people so
like a lot of people in this in our
little gaming community came on doing
you too yeah so I got I'm an addict
that's how I met COG and pretty much
everybody else on iron Lords it involved
was an arsenal red dragon I'm a ton of
people's because I rode with that you
know you get some developer contacts and
you know it was fun it was kind of like
it I want to say it was the Wild West
but it really wasn't right but it was it
was more like you know I would probably
liken it to like you know like in The
Godfather there's like five families and
everyone's going after each other but I
was trying to be civil right like that
sometimes I feel like when when I'm
looking at who's doing podcasts on what
day and who's doing what it's it's
almost like you have to keep an eye and
go alright well this person's doing a
podcast this day well we don't aggravate
them oh it's oh this person's doing a
podcast this day we don't we don't want
to like overlap them and it's almost to
the point where like I keep calling a
boom like the godfather of podcasts
because like he's like the elder
statesman because he does so much and
he's all over the place just like X ba
and and salty and all those guys and you
want to have that respect for them
because they've been doing this stuff so
long that's why it was very difficult
for us to find a time slot to
to make sure it didn't overlap with one
of them because we knew we you know that
we want people to go see them we want
people to go see us everyone so believe
me I know well that brings me up
tomatoes my question for like well
question comment like when we when we
spoke like I really wanted you to come
on kind of earlier in the time of when
we started the podcast because I knew
that you know you have a great story of
how you kind of grew up in in that
community and you were like I can't do
Mondays I have the multiverse and I was
like I thought I thought it was every
like twice a month I didn't realize it
was every week um and that's why like
yesterday it was was it was my
anniversary with my wife so I was like
I'm like this is perfect I can ask you
to come on Tuesday because I know I know
you can't have multiverse done you can't
say hey I have a two days a row because
that would just be mean so uh like
alright well I'm like this is gonna be
great to have you on so so it's great so
I say hey I when I was doing YouTube and
well the podcasts were not really
popular when I was starting doing
YouTube it wasn't too much later because
for what happen with me was I was about
I think it was about 2015 no 314 I
forget but um I got asked to go on tech
podcast originally and I was like one of
like the fifth episode or something like
that and then it was funny because like
I I do the same exact thing I do what
everyone everyone's podcast I felt
terrible for it later because I was
playing Battlefield 4 the whole time and
I was answering questions and yeah I
because I'm pretty good at multitasking
about that but he was funny I did that
entire interview and then literally the
next interview they got was Phil Spencer
right that was like damn it
it was it was a good it was a good show
and eventually got asked to join tech
podcast I joined and I worked with taken
to their stuff for a while and my I
tenure ended with them but that's all
good fun I don't regret anything about
it so rim and and now you are working
with the air loads podcast doing
lugnut stuff and multiple other things
in the background I'm the Godfather of
iron Lords dude
III mean that quite literally no no no
III yes they do a podcast yes yes I
heard I've heard the background
information of how you know you supposed
to the guys and say you should do this
you should do this you should bring on
these people I I've heard I've heard the
background information and it's it's
pretty interesting I'm hoping to get
take a cog one of these one of these
days when he's got a day off and bring
him in here so he can you know go
through the whole story of iron Louis
podcasts and things like that because
it's a it's a very it's a very
interesting story so your time frame
would for with tick was was a couple it
was a couple years and then you did
multiple different things with them
right and then when when did the
multiverse start when you were over
there
um so originally when I was doing the I
would say I get I picked up I got asked
formally to join in 2015 I believe so I
joined them in 2015 and I worked I
didn't do a lot of writing but I was
working as a creative director and
basically managing all the podcasts and
such mm-hmm I was going through that
process then I went to e3 with them in
2016 that was that was always that's a
certainly experience yeah because I was
like right after that everyone started
splitting up and everything so yeah
because I was like right after that look
like column where he already left and
then there's no it was Greg Greg Miller
and Collin left you could do kind of
funny and then like the year after that
think Greg column left just it was a
bunch of stuff happened like a bunch of
everyone started moving and changing cuz
then I was like Meg Turney left
everybody started leaving after 2016 it
was it was kind of nuts but um yeah I
said so I did I did that time frame with
them and that's when we got iron Lords
on tick and so they kind of got them
started up and what else happened after
that while you're thinking that I just
wanna I just wanna throw out uh yes
salty and irrelevant native yes cog
busy man at night shifts so yes he is
too good for his own podcast but believe
it or not this podcast was actually it
was an idea that me and him through well
I pitched to him for a while and do you
kind of finally was like go for I see
how it goes and was brought in but yes
he can't he can't afford this podcast so
hopefully one day what he ends up
getting like I said I want to get him on
here as soon as he can get nightshift I
know he's off this week so I might I
might try to sneak in another episode
this week but we have to see or I'll
have to talk to him next time he's on
vacation but yeah you were saying
Voltaire so yeah so what happened was it
what we were doing we were doing took
podcast and we pitched around this idea
of doing like a we were gonna talk about
doing a website and one of the things
also came up was like well we can't
really talk about anything other than
Xbox that sick podcast so we can't
really do anything which was really kind
of frustrating because like we all have
we all had other interests like things
we wanted to talk about but we really
could do anything about and so I was
really frustrating for no me and Cal and
so we talked about doing a show making
it more of a like I like a anime comic
book kind of thing and so we started
doing a pre-recorded show and we called
it multiverse show no I just
it was it was something to call it I
didn't really have much else to call it
but it was it worked out really well but
I hated doing the that show I mean of
doing it because it was just really
really it was just really annoying to
record and then edit the entire thing it
was really frustrating I hated doing
that because it was pre-recorded you
felt the need to edit it yeah I felt I
felt like if we're gonna pre record it
we got to edit it right it's not it was
really frustrated me and so we did that
for like ten episodes and so that was
like an hour and a half of content I had
to edit I was like oh that's I wanted
that anymore and so we kind of scrapped
it after a while and then was a Fame and
I Fame entertainment he and I said like
we wanna do a podcast
and says like well I have this name for
multiverse show we can just take that
instead mm-hmm
we're not using it and says all right
cool obviously well we're sort of
brainstorming about like what will we do
with the show what we make it different
cuz right now this is during the podcast
crazy everyone everyone everyone
everyone's doing one that's how we make
it different all right first of all
we're gonna put about Mondays cuz no one
has a podcast on Mondays which is true
nobody had a podcast on Mondays right
Sara was doing like weekends or twos
like Friday Friday Friday Thursday later
of the week and so we were thinking like
alright what if we um if we put our show
like on we put it on a Monday if it's a
Monday we don't have to compete with
anybody else
plus you got people at you know we put
at 8 o'clock 9 o'clock I think we were
doing at nine o'clock originally yeah
and so I was like everyone else like
they're all waiting to play like if it's
a game release because most games
release on like Tuesdays or Fridays
right and so we were saying hey we you
know one day night people are just kind
of killing time waiting for the next
game to come out what if we kind of like
came on it's like this hype show for
whatever the next game is so like if if
fallout 4 was coming out on Tuesday we
would like we talked about fallout 4 why
we're excited for and like maybe cut a
little bit of gaming news let's do
something different though everyone else
is like doing this like these three
hour-long shows the stuff for that it's
stressful why you staying in there for
three hours week after week and like
yeah it's fun I don't get me wrong but I
can't do that regular basis I got stuff
to do right and so I decided like let's
just make it 45 minutes so it's like
people come in come out it's just an
hour max and the people have time right
so we did that and it worked really well
we we got a good little following we did
a couple little things here so we uh we
also did like little events and stuff so
we do a little giveaways and we also did
like we kind of try to do the what's
called like all right now no you did our
own Game of the Year Show which actually
we just did this year's we also did we
also do like the the
gamer Awards and so we would kind of
like highlight individuals in the
community who we thought were like
interesting like we like a fight it like
best podcast at 28 2016 or we would do
like funniest gamer or little things
like that so people get nominated we
really got people like from around our
little community and nominate other
people and like that actually got a
really good following of people people
love that stuff and the funny part was
really used to do with Rookie of the
Year but the funny part was with Rookie
of the Year
we actually got we actually nominated in
like people who won actually went on and
became like big better bigger youtubers
so we're like oh like a one-year was
Kofi here was Jay main was the other one
there was there was somebody else and
like they they're completely off the map
now and we have no idea where they are
but but like like we had people were
winning Rookie of the Year and just it
was funny cuz we kept like highlighting
the people who went on being way bigger
that we were helped you kind of help
pave the way for these people so they
can kind of understand and see what
they're looking at I mean they had
talent they just needed a little push
yeah yeah I need reassurance
it helps yes so um so a relevant need of
it made a comment before in chat about
the game of the year for you what do you
mean by that
alright so every year we do a Game of
the Year Show we're actually doing that
and a film of the year show ok well that
will be next week for film of the year
then we're done for the year because we
get the way everything falls and we fall
on Christmas Eve yeah New Year's Eve
right so it's like well we can't really
do that can't we right
I can't ask people to do that but um was
it so the way we do our show I love
about it is that it's entirely
transparent everybody sees the entire
process from nominee all the way through
you see who game of the year is and we
do it in a way that systematically
pisses off each of us everything so the
way the system works and like it's been
refined over the years but as a general
process what we
do is each of us nominates five games
everyone on the panel gets five games to
nominate with those nominees we kind of
we kind of finesse things a little bit
so what we do is out of those five we
assemble the list of all the nominees so
if all of us so at the last night we had
six different people and so each of us
had five anyone who got multiple
nominations kind of survived longer
those who got single nominations were
free to be on the chopping block yeah
what we would do is that we would go one
by one and we don't talk about which
game we think is better
we just think which game is worse right
and so what we do is we go one by one
and I'll be like oh I nominate death
stranding to be eliminated from the list
and with the route votes on whether or
not they gonna do it by civil majority
and so last night a bunch of gate well
we got all the way through and so we got
stuck on the top five and we were at a
complete stalemate no one no one would
vote to get rid of any of the games of
the list like we would through every
single one that was possible and
everyone got stalemated and so really no
one could get out of there so what we
did is we we put it on we had to put up
a vote we actually opened it up to the
chat and so out of the five and so we
say okay the first three people the
first few would respond would get to
pick which game gets eliminated just
based on like just the first ones to
respond right and so we've said to look
for like two votes and then we're gonna
say we're gonna go with that that'll be
enough to choose which one I get rid of
and so originally what they did it the
plague tail was gonna get eliminated but
then one of our guys use their veto
power just stop just stop it from being
eliminated and so the next scheme they
got eliminated was Resident Evil 2 oh
really and four of our people on the
show nominated that game it was the most
nominated game but they because they use
their vetoes incorrectly they said they
tried to save plague tale only to have
Resident Evil limits
I personally made side note I think
resident evil she cannot shouldn't be
considered Game of the Year because I I
am with you on that I think if it's a
remake
you are basically rewriting the same
idea and you're doing you're doing it
again but yeah it could be way better
more up-to-date game but it's still the
same game still the same game I'm sorry
I can't good constants say that's better
than any other game no she came out this
year is brand new yeah I'm sorry
I understand that it is considered a
quote-unquote new game for people of a
younger generation but at the same time
you can for instance world of warcraft
right the game's been around since 2004
they just released work Warcraft classic
and all these people are playing it
because it's fresh and new to them but
you cannot say that scheme of the year
because that was it's 2004 I'm sorry
that it just doesn't make sense to me
it's this it's literally they took the
same game they put better graphics on it
and for like best ongoing game or
something like that
I mean hey go go right ahead I think
that's why I like that category in the
game of words every year right category
because you see games that like actually
turn around the only game that has not
won that award that truly deserves as
Rainbow six siege the the they should
take all remakes make a new genre and
say best remade game of the year because
now there's like 7 8 9 10 remakes every
year so you can pretty much make your
own category for him now but you can
never consider them as a game of the
year I'm sorry I agree I don't think
ever be considered as game of the year
because if it wins game of the year
what does that say about modern games
yeah 10 years ago was better than yours
yeah Millennials you're screwing
everything up napkin um yes it's so so
what
being your game of the year not mine
well let me clarify this my game of the
year was Jedi fallen order I fully agree
it was Jedi fallen order after party and
in outer worlds
those are my gear picks they did not
make it
our worlds got number two I will say
that much had a fool in order to cut
fallen order got cut because they'd like
other like Sakura more and yeah and
while they didn't like because of bugs
and it was like this felt they felt like
they was rushed I'm like no fair about
care yeah I I still think that as of
right now
giaffone order is probably one of the
best games I played in a very long time
and I think that everyone should go out
and give it a try and play it because
this story is fantastic I'm almost done
with that I've been like kind of like
chipping away at it little by little by
little playing an hour here an hour
there two hours here two hours there and
kind of just going at it and it's it's
really hard because I've been playing on
Jedi Master and I love it it's so good
yeah for me like I but I liked about
Jedi fallen order was just the fact that
that game see there's a whole there's
another sub-genre of like souls clones
and stuff I don't want it is not a souls
clone it is taking that it's a combat
system that recipe for of like souls
games of like you know limited health
regen you know the focus on dodging and
parrying and it's taking that aspect but
i'm actually starting to like that
sub-genre where it's like okay it's not
about brutal punishment it's just about
challenge yeah you think out your
encounters like what is that I like that
and I also like darks Darksiders 3
another game that I thought was really
enjoyable because of that system they
made more challenging and it made where
it was just like you know completely
hack and slash brutal melee stuff and
making it more of a okay I mean I could
still do that but I want to feel like a
badass because I'm able to manage my
health and be able to use bye
effectively for the scenario that calls
for I fully agree with you I in that
particular that would focus well
Jennifer order basically replaced what
like where Darksiders focused more on
like enemy variety and combat styles
this one they did it said nah let's just
make it more exploration based yeah I
got charted or a Tomb Raider it took
those aspects and I enjoyed that a lot
well swim respawn who the same people
that made Uncharted yes so but like
that's been charted the viewers for my
understanding what are the people on
there yes from for my understanding the
people that made Uncharted don't quote
me on this I I have to double check my
my resources but for my understanding
the people that made Uncharted
eventually left Uncharted and created
respawn and respawn ended up then
creating the Jedi fallen order and
that's that's that's to do with respawn
they are the guys who worked on call of
duty modern warfare original Infinity
Ward guys I used to be yes pretty much
pretty much yes but like that's so those
guys we just beat shooter yeah that's
that is interesting yeah but they do say
good story you can't say that those guys
don't get to give it a good story
because all the all the Call of Duty's
when they actually had first player
stories we're pretty good still there
yeah I thought you were like oh oh but
yeah that's that was my two cents so
going back to multiverse back so
originally when you created that with
the multiverse itself it's essentially a
based on movies anime now tilt can you
explain to people that you know are
listening what you know that content is
and what like your main focus was
within like whatever we originally start
doing a prerecorded it was movies anime
and all that kind of stuff when we
started making our own podcast we we
shifted more towards gaming but like
gaming was 50% of it mm-hmm the comics
were like 25 each yes so we made that
more the focus so we would do like a
three topic show and like two topics
would be gaming and then one topic
movies or comics or something like that
focus was but like over time you know
more topics and so much so you you
yourself are a huge comic book fan um I
used to be like a major comic book fan
I don't read as many comics as I used to
I'm actually I sold my entire comic
collection to get an Xbox one Oh wanna
all of I sold most of them yeah I still
have a few I'm just sitting in there
waiting on like this will be valuable
one day in my collection I will keep
them forever
it literally have a box of like help
like comics and you know what's called
this like Thunderbolt it's um it's some
stupid comic I don't care about me a
bunch of them and they're like one
through like a hundred and they're
sitting in a box and I know eventually
they're gonna make a movie of it
eventually I'm just gonna wait I was
gonna sit there they're in their own
little sleeves they're gonna be fine I'm
gonna wait so I eventually I know a
comic that movie will come out yes when
I was when I was younger
probably almost about a senior in high
school my dad and I would go to comic
book shows and I used to have like huge
collections of like Wolverine comics and
Superman comics and and I've like the
venom comics and gambits comics like I
ended up having this huge collection of
first editions of those comics because
you know I was I was a huge fan of them
and now I'm seven sitting on them and I
have them boarded and protected and
everything I'm just thinking to myself
if I do this right then I will
definitely be able to make some some
money off of them because they're not
like they're not like the secretary
third prince those are like the original
first prints with
the gold covers or whatever this or the
platinum covers the really really rare
stuff because those are the ones I ended
up picking up so I I I love having a
copper collection and I haven't I
haven't really expanded on that in a
really long time but I think that my
whole entire love for comics is now like
shifted into watching different animes
and reading mangas and stuff when I go
into the when I go into like borders and
stuff I don't actually buy mangas I just
go to the store and just read them off
the shelves those are so short but yeah
exactly exactly are you are you a fan
also of that type of stuff um I used to
read manga like in high school
I'll watch the enemy every once in a
while but I like bins the entire series
and just be open I don't watch it very
often it just kind of comes it goes I
don't really like for me TV shows in
general are really hard for me to get
into mm-hmm only because I just don't
care about them as much I'm more of a
film person mmm with film you have
limitations and so you have to do a lot
of like filmmaking shorthand right yep
they a coherent thought in two hours
right
we're like a TV show you could just not
talk about it for a very long time and
they're like oh yeah this random obscure
little thing we could have like actually
assured off with like five seconds of
dialogue nah we're just gonna hold up a
whole episode about it and like it feels
and like yeah that's cool and that's a
cool benefit the TV has but I don't
really I just don't care about it that
much
and I I prefer film as a general concept
well it's a couple shows I've watched it
got really into so right now I don't
know why everything in chat it throws
bushes at the end guys so I apologize um
so now I remember you and King talking
about you guys possibly doing something
for Rock the Mandalorian and things like
that now I assume you've ended up
watching it oh yeah the only thing about
it though is just the timings weird on
it like this because I like the fact
that Disney Plus is like really kind of
staggering them out right wait we'll see
especially like for me
status stuff like the baby Yoda thing so
the only reason why it's lasted this
long is because they're drip-feeding the
content what's a week right
I've only I only saw the first two
episodes I've been meaning to watch the
rest of them but I've been trying to
make a conscious effort to not watch
something once I'm watching with my dad
one thing about it the only thing about
the show I'm not like super into is just
that every episode feels different and
it's cuz they have different directors
and stuff and that's fine they just
doesn't like the firt I like the tone of
the first episode a lot and it like
shifts like the tone changes a lot but
then it goes it goes back and forth I'm
like okay like like Episode five I won't
say anything about don't let spoil it
for you it was a five I like the tone of
us a five I like and like but like two
and three we're like okay these are cool
wasn't it so what into I was fine with
three and four I'm like yeah I styled
not for me well I actually was listening
to a podcast with one of the individuals
that created a lot of the original pilot
episodes I'm blanking on the individuals
name but he ended up creating things
like Smallville what the heck is it
called he ended up doing 32 total pilots
supernatural flash green arrow legends
of tomorrow he did a bunch of different
ones that he said that like a lot of the
times what ends up happening is he also
did Game of Thrones like you did he was
brought in right and he would produce
this amazing like pilot episode and then
the content would end up getting picked
up and then he would end up having
another person come in for the next
couple of episodes and he would sit
there with them and explained to him
what what he's gonna do and where
they're looking to put the path and then
after that he was gone so that's that's
what I think the whole entire problem is
with with the TV with like episode alep
Assad all type shows because you have
individuals that are gonna make this
amazing pilot just like the Mandalorian
was and then after that it's just
feel kind of empty for a couple of
episodes until they get the groove and a
lot of the times like if if Yuri if
you've heard the film industry talk they
say that they don't hit their stride
until the third season but most shows
never make a third season and then it's
kind of you know they're done no yeah
that is a problem it's really hard for
them to continue the same also either
you have a breakout first season you get
the problem of like following it up you
have that issue sometimes other times
it's like okay what's the like what what
does this show really about yeah it's
it's it's crazy it's crazy so so you end
up having the multiverse is there any
other podcast that you have that you are
you know you work with or is it just
that one that is my only podcast that I
currently routinely show up on right and
then the your YouTube channel do you
still end up producing content for that
or is it just it is on my youtube
channel it's been completely redone
right that okay all right also I I I
didn't know if you you ended up still
like you know slot like once in a while
you're like oh I like this review this
game never or into well I'll put
something out there but as a general
rule I don't tell anybody about that did
you think that like you know doing this
build-up for your your YouTube channel
is gonna be as difficult as what it was
oh it's a completely different beast now
yeah it's entirely different night I
don't have a problem with it honestly it
just it's coming see well the thing that
I always always tell people about it is
just that if you are into something and
you want to see yourself succeed you
gotta read the market and like the
market came and went for what I was
doing and I basically quit doing YouTube
for a while and I try it I try to come
back a little bit and like I just don't
why
I have the same spark because a lot of
it has to do with like you routinely
putting out content every single day or
at least having a pretty routine
it's fine but I'm not in college anymore
I don't have that kind of time yeah I
have a real life I have to deal with
like I just don't have that time anymore
like might like to give you an idea of
what I was doing in college I literally
would not do anything it nowhere at
school like I I remember taking classes
not paying attention at all and just
writing scripts for YouTube videos yeah
game play and everything else I was just
doing all that prep work so I would get
off I would get off go to my apartment
hide my head under a blanket record the
record the audio and then pump out a
video every day and that was great for
the time yeah I can't do that anymore
cuz I just don't have that kind of time
to do that every so often I'll put
something out there do it every so often
something come out but it I gotta be
really inspired and have good chuck a
free time because people don't
understand making videos takes time it
does you think it should so so for
instance for us for the ILP stuff would
be the first look videos what ends up
happening is the the stream team guys
will actually the team will actually do
the videos they'll do the recording of
them talking and they end up sending the
videos and stuff to myself and what I
end up doing is I end up taking the
videos I cut them change them edit them
speed up certain portions change sound
here and there I do pop ups and all that
stuff and I tell them I'm like I don't
want you guys doing it because it's a
pain in the butt it takes a lot of time
I don't want you guys to you know kill
yourself during time because I actually
I can a lot time during the like a lot
of time during the week to take care of
all of my ILP works I like to call it
and I get to get that stuff done and
then we can get our videos out
it does it takes a lot a lot of time
it's it's it's it's very interesting to
see you know that stuff happened now you
know right now for ILP you're doing like
that you've taken over the thumbnails
and stuff like that to do those stuff
you're using Photoshop for the for that
though for your imaging or you hand
drawing I'm sorry not the is the secret
it is a much more I say it's a much more
approachable editing software yeah if
you're if you want to try to photo
editing it's you can mod the crap out of
it so much stuff you could do with it I
have been using that for years and it's
free
I mean it's donation where you can you
donate if you want to yeah you could
also get ton a ton of great stuff and I
basically taught myself everything right
so I've it's really not that difficult
if you got time for it right yeah that's
because I know that you did that and
what do you what did you end up doing
with your videos you you don't you don't
use that stuff anymore because you use
oh yes so for my videos i still do i
still use paint.net to make every all
the title cards and stuff is i use obs
for recording no discord because
eventually I know Google said they're
gonna be getting rid of Google Hangouts
so if they haven't already done so so we
basically jumped ahead of that did that
yeah I know I know a lot of people are
waiting for it to happen and oh I see
this is this gonna be the great culling
of YouTube so yeah well it's gonna be
very interesting to see how things
change because if you have a podcast you
got to be dedicated now yeah well that's
the thing for us at least we were
working on something on the back end to
make sure that we're we're working but
as of right now we're just continuing
using Google Hangouts because everybody
choices it's easy for the people coming
in so we're gonna we're gonna use it
until it wasn't for Google Hangouts most
podcast wouldn't exists correct because
it's bad that one link button that would
send it right right easy it was it was
truly a beautiful thing I really I miss
you know not having that this this time
has needed to come free good long
while some people's podcast I'm gonna
say it not very good production quality
wise they need to step up the game yes
it's time for that yes so you've been
you've been working on podcasts
YouTube's game and stuff now for I would
say then for the past nine ish years
tennis years this entire generation okay
so okay so when you kind of brought that
up to your to like your family and your
friends and stuff like that that you
were gonna be doing this podcast and
things like that were they were very
supportive of that or were they kind of
just yes they were confused by that what
is a podcast well it's not so much that
by the podcast cuz like my parents
didn't really care about what I was
doing as long as I was like having good
grades
yeah and it was a good it was a good way
to do make you know I made a little
extra money but wasn't much yeah I more
had to explain working for a website
with that so yeah yeah it's kind of
interesting like when when we go to when
I go out to and I've said this before on
the podcast when I go out to the mall or
federal food shop and stuff like that I
always have like yeah my my my my logo
shirts and my toys OD and stuff like
that and people ask me questions and
stuff like that and I kind of give him
my card and they're like what do you do
now and I'm like oh I do this and I work
for an internet website publication
doing gaming stuff and that's all I've
kind of like learned till I go word it
now so people understand it's yeah
they're not looking at me like I have
four heads this is like well you do what
you just wait you'll eventually get to
the point to where like people will
recognize you directly I that's happened
to me a couple of times
and from the weirdest of places yeah I I
actually had this one guy that I met at
like Trader Joe's right and I gave him
my business card because he saw me
because of the twitch early and he's
actually now regular on my Twitter
station but it was really weird cuz
though every time I go in there now he's
like what's up Pete what do you do and
I'm like what's up Greg
so it's like a really interesting and
it's also at the same time because you
know you can make that relation to you
know your fan base so it's kind of cool
and it also gives you like this
this is good like warm feeling inside so
it's good like I had a buddy it was
funny because actually I was doing
YouTube and I care what the the starting
incident was I was was it oh I remember
what happened so one time is whatever
Batman Arkham Knight was coming out
because my brother app to go to the arc
of night release things you always want
to go to like a release thing like
you'll stay up till midnight go go get
your game and do that kind of thing so
like my brothers like three years
younger than me so I was all right cool
let's go do that and I had been like a
couple but not like a lot and so we're
over a Gamestop and so I'm what we were
talking about and I was just kind of
like around just kind of I wasn't
bothering anybody this is like right
around the time whatever
backwards-compatibility got announced
right right and right at that point I
was trying to do it was I was looking
for a Mass Effect I was looking for a
Mass Effect on 360 so I could give it a
shot I didn't like the fact I didn't
have a ton of games to work with right
it's how I wanted to give it a shot so I
was looking through that and like this
guy comes up to me and he's just like
hey man you should get a PlayStation 4
I'm like pointing myself like me like
like are you paying for kids he's got
all these great games and stuff I'm like
all right cool
I don't care like yeah I'm just from
Mass Effect's like a player try
backwards-compatibility out see all that
PlayStation 4 has got backwards
compatibility I'm like no it doesn't and
so he just keeps talking about all this
stuff and he was like oh man it's got
this game this game and it's like it was
like dude you're talking about the wrong
person I don't care yeah I already know
you're full of it like yeah like you
don't know what you're talking about and
so so this guy came up to me and I call
him Shane every time we're talking about
stuff on
- I don't want to get him trouble but
and so he comes up to me and he's like
I'm sorry about that guy I don't know
who he is he just wants he's like a 40
year old man and he keeps trying to like
sell people things and I'm like he
doesn't work here I don't know who he is
this house like I do it's fine and so we
started talking and so he was like yeah
man I say what say what do you do I'm
like oh yeah well you know about the
backwards-compatibility thing so this
was like a couple days like later some
like that you know about that and like
it's not widespread yeah yeah and so
what's the deal so we started talking
for a while as I did YouTube and so
alright cool man it's amazing is so
Shane every so often will help hook me
up or something if I have something
comes out like you got me a deal on the
X give a man on the inside
yeah I will see you Shane every couple
of weeks we'll see you in the next Xbox
or Playstation or whoever else drops out
yes yes so I want I want to know what is
your obsession with the Fallout series
or is it considered to fall out or
Bethesda as a whole
everyone says I'm a huge division IP fan
but I'm more of a Ubisoft fan
so it's like more about franchise things
so that's why I was curious if it was
Bethesda or if it was just a fallout
stuff so lame premise is this way so why
I had not played a Bethesda game until
2011 okay because I didn't get I didn't
get a 360 until 2011 so I turned 18
mm-hmm I remember getting a 360 so it's
really catch up on stuff like a buddy of
mine grant like hey man you gotta play
fallout 3 like it's got it's got a bunch
of chunk I was like what do you mean is
like there's like junk laying all over
the place you could pick it up okay
that's rad
yeah it's like I get like if all three
hated it
cuz three I'd played an open-world RPG
like that where like things are not very
clear-cut where you're supposed to go
what you're supposed to do like I was
not used to that at all as I go I walk
out and like I did a couple of things
that you'll go to Megaton as I own you
talk to Moriarty Moriarty's like oh yeah
I know where your dad went but what's in
it for me that's all right I understand
you're supposed to be a jerk so sure
I'll do something for you saying that
information I get the informations all
right cool
so I saw him heading towards a DC the or
ahead of the mall alright cool so I head
over there meet three dog and three
other yeah I saw your dad I'm not
telling you nothing till you do
something for me I'm like I thought you
were supposed to be like a really cool
person about being a jerk yeah it's a
you do this thing almost get killed it's
a yeah I saw your dad he went that way
it's like wait I thought you knew
exactly where he was then he it's the
same exact thing I'm like you know what
I'm done I quit like just tell me where
my dad is already I'm tired of this yeah
why didn't we do the side quests or
anything I quit I stopped playing time
goes on
Skyrim came out I was a weird roommate
situation we'll talk about that
besides played a lot of Skyrim loved
Skyrim got into it great playing
hundreds of hours of Skyrim I was I was
great loved Bethesda that was great
and then after a while I get I was it
was right after 2012 and I remember
right now Far Cry 3 at a used place and
I got a little a few more dollars I'd
like $10 extra and I could I bought
Fallout New Vegas I forgot about follow
three existing okay and so I finished
Far Cry 3 and I was oh man i far cry 3
was great like I need a gaming gig wine
down wet light
no no game could be that great twice
after like two games two in a row back
to excellent games back to back can't
possibly happen
I play follow to Vegas loved it I
absolutely fell in love with Fallout New
Vegas it was great my favorite game like
still my favorite Fallout game to this
day absolutely love it play the crap out
of it eventually I was like I played it
I played it so much
not just like wait a minute follow three
that's the same franchise like so I went
back to it now knowing what I know about
Fallout New Vegas and like I liked it as
much as New Vegas I still enjoyed it a
lot and I would did side missions and
all this other crazy fun stuff that they
had I really enjoyed that going through
that whole process it was it was really
a really a blast and so since then I'm
in kind of a big Bezdek guy yeah like
this is great I like Skyrim I like
excited so why everybody says of a big
fallout fan more than usual I I like
fought a lot like I'm not gonna kill
anybody for it
the funny part about the entire thing
was so I was at a gaming group called we
game here for it got announced I was
really excited I had like three videos
about it I was like yeah I was like
crying and they was like obvious can be
the best game ever
it was it it so people when I post that
video were like in the comments for like
in on Facebook that happens really oh
well the fallouts boring I don't care
about fallout it's like you shouldn't
post this I'm like excuse me as like
just for that alone I'm going to troll
the absolute crap out of you until the
game comes out so every single day
without fail at a countdown post a new
post every single day on that gaming
group and I only that but I made sure to
trash whatever game was coming out at
that same time yeah and so if you like
oh yeah Tomb Raider doomed Tomb Raider
no chance whatsoever true but but like
any other game that was coming out that
was popular at the time
maybe equivalent would be like Oh death
stranding boring fall
to Vegas did the courier game first I do
stuff like that just just to troll
people I got so mad people quit the
group people people banned me wow it was
a bit overkill I'll admit that much it
was really fun so it's gaming like these
people shouldn't be complaining or even
bothering it just if that's what you
enjoyed then just play it yeah it didn't
matter but yeah I mean it was one of
those things where it was like hey you
didn't like this Santa I'm gonna make
sure you always remember oh my god so
yeah it's a fun it's a fun little thing
I did back then but so then whatever
fallout new vegas fallout 76 ski tour
was announced I was one I was really
happy because I kind of predicted it
sort of like a written Ischl II when it
was announced I wasn't before it was
announced I said I remember cuz I was I
was on a podcast I said this like
another Fallout game was gonna come out
this year yeah no it's not no it's not
it's the new skyrim it's you know
whatever game it is and I was like no
it's gonna be another fallout game it's
it right no no it's not gonna be that I
said look they keep supporting things on
Fallout 4 yeah bringing new mods and a
lot of the mods we're seeing in this our
quality of life mods things that are
people who things people would want a
regular basis they're trying to sell you
these mods not the free ones these are
the the Creation Kit ones and I was like
they're trying to sell you on these mods
that means this is not done base they
want to do more yeah
and so then eventually it actually was
true yeah
they follow 76 was announced and so I
mean because fall 76 was not made for
normal fans of the game yeah follow 36
was made for me and me alone it's about
for your time that's all it's about
right anything else in
people like it's not made for the
average person to get on and play it's
made for the people who can't get enough
a fallout yeah the people that are the
fought addicts so that they want to play
more yep
yeah it's basic stuff that makes that
make sense
that's like a lot of people that they
have a love arc or like Conan was called
Conan mags Isles or like seven days to
die like those are those people that
they can't get enough of like you know
that type of a timeframe genre type
thing and that's how 476 is it's it does
a lot of a lot of good things and
there's a lot of bad things and it
doesn't matter to two people that are in
love with the game and that's the most
important thing the people that play it
they like it and they enjoy it and if
there's bugs or if they're they excel in
certain things it's it's their thing
they love it you know that's that's how
that's how I can to think of it so yeah
so I wanna I want to ask you I times
actually flew I just looked up at the
clock I don't know it's what time it was
I wanted to ask you one final question
before we do our exit and this is
something I asked everyone that is on
the show if you could live in one
fantasy world or environment what would
it be it could be a movie could be TV
show it could be a comic book
it could be an anime anywhere you know
like Harry Potter Star Wars you know any
of that stuff am i do i am i living as a
implicit MPC like a regular person in
that world or my living is like as a
hero doesn't matter are words like I'm a
Jedi or something like that or if it's
like Star Wars you could be a Jedi if
you're like the world of harry potter
you could be a wizard you could be a
muzzle it doesn't matter it depends upon
you as a person like how you'd want to
live like you can you know that you'd be
an npc if you are because if it's if I'm
living as like a normal MPC or something
like that
mm-hmm like that that answer is very
different than as I oh yeah I'm living
as a superhero and doing whatever it
doesn't matter it's solely a hundred
percent preferable to you if you rather
if you
rather live in the world of let's say
Skyrim as a NPC would you be okay with
that would you if you want to live in
like you know Star Wars and you want to
be a Jedi can you do that
if like I said it doesn't matter you can
you can live however which way you want
to live you know if you want to be
living in the world of like the flash
and you want it to be a person like
there's just a regular human being
walking around or if you want it to be
like you know the flash the Batman wants
just be that but let's see I asked I
asked a similar question the people are
just in general like okay which which
invite which which which world do what
you want to live in like as a as
yourself Mike
Bioshock like yeah if you're Andrew Ryan
where you can live and die and just kind
of whatever you want sure right yeah so
totally fine but on the other hand like
if you're like a regular Joe Schmo in
the world of Bioshock you're screwed
trying to kill you all the time I wish I
prepare for that II would not live in
the world of Fallout if I could say like
hey I would have no problem living in
the world of warcraft because I we just
resurrected every five minutes if I
wanted to yeah like it's like that but
that's like the NPC's iam and they die
and come back so why does it matter
anymore it would be more like just
really annoying oh yeah they killed me
again oh my shorts yeah you don't if you
if you feel that it is a too difficult
answer I mean well no it's nearly
narrowing down which ones I would like
more or is this is this the
philosophical brain of yours that is
that is ticking
yeah I guess like on one hand like I
like the aesthetic style of like outer
worlds but they're living in a heavy
corporate of mine will be annoying as
hell that's that's right yeah you know
it sounded really weird
go for it go for it I'm down to your
worth ins I've had people say they want
to live in the land of Silent Hill so I
you know I'm calling you out old-school
stylez I'm calling you out like so I've
heard some weird things I'm gonna see
Italy dangerous elite dangerous really
you'd like to be that person flying
around in a spaceship well it's not so
much that as much as it is like there's
laws and stuff like it's not like the
Wild West like things happen see I'm
thinking more from the perspective of
like okay this world
like is there recourse for me to like
okay like I think okay someone like
griefing me but okay yeah like okay yeah
they keep blowing up my ship or
something like that and it's like this
is so frustrating
like someone keeps attacking me and just
keeps doing this it's so frustrating
I would but like elite dangerous there's
like there's laws and there's like
penalties and like you you break a law
you have a bounty on your heads people
kill you for the bounty they take that
money
yeah it's relatively controlled like the
the economy is fluid things change it's
I I think I want to live in that world
because it also like good piloting
skills but you could also like you're
you're flexible yeah it's like if your
ship gets blown up yeah I don't have to
buy a whole new one you just pay your
insurance octavo like yeah been a
detective really go just take your life
with my car have you played have any
play star citizen yeah no no I have not
played star citizen has I can't even
come out officially yet no it's still
like made a decision I'm not playing any
alphas and betas anymore I'll do a test
weekend but that's about it
I'm not beta testing for free
right I ended up picking up one of the
one of the things one of the packages
because I had a bunch of friends asking
me to pick it up and play with them and
I actually I played it for a little bit
and it's fun but you you need a joystick
or two joysticks and you need to have
someone tell you what to do because
there's like no tutorial and so it's
really difficult to start off in play if
you don't know how to play you have you
played elite dangerous
I have not I've seen a lot of people
play go play that it's a completed
version of the game that is just better
yeah I've seen it and I do want to play
it but your podcast of the background
and go be a space trucker
cuz for me like I I don't really play I
don't I don't like being a mercenary in
that game I don't like it like it's just
it's not my thing I don't like being a
miner I like being a smuggler because
it's a risk and it's enjoyable like yeah
if you if you get caught like yeah
you're gonna have a huge fine
like no we're like it's a cat tax you
want site yeah like an imperial system
go pick up a couple slaves take them to
the federal the federal area make a good
make a good easy million and then just
cut dip out like you have to get to park
yourself so you don't get like caught
the scans and such there's there's a
game that I backed on Kickstarter a long
time ago called a chronicles of ilaria
have you ever heard of it I have heard
of it that's the one that's like they're
based out of Rhode Island I'm like the
entire C government got involved in that
I don't know what that what isn't that
the guy who also had a like he's like a
baseball guy really back today I think
I'm thinking about I don't know I don't
I I don't I don't know of that
but this game is pretty much it's it's
based on governing parties and
individuals and you know you have your
king that takes care of your county and
then you have your account that breaks
down to cut the there that area in two
duchies and it's a counties and two into
settlements and it kind of breaks down
and literally
really really interesting and I ended up
getting involved in it but when it was
Kickstarter and they allotted me like a
mayor of one of the settlements and
being involved in that game that isn't
even out yet it's so intense and the
forum boards are always going nuts out
the discord is always going nuts and
like because I'm a mayor of one of these
towns essentially like I'm on all these
email notifications and I'm like oh what
was that Kingdoms of Amalur that's what
the game was oh like like this game
chronicles of ilaria I can't wait to see
how it comes out because of they have
this like spark system which is like you
buy a spark which is $35 and then you
end up having this spark for up to 12
months and what ends up happening is
like if you die it actually takes days
away from your spark so like you know
you could like burn through a spark
within like ten months instead of you're
a lot of 12 but if you're like a king
you know your time is your time frame
isn't 12 months it's technically eight
months and then once I spark dies you
end up buying in and you can get you you
know when you buy your next we every
time you die your child then takes your
your like all your abilities and
everything like that but you start again
as like a level one kind of like it's
it's a real interesting kind of engine
and thought process for for a game it's
really gonna be nice when it comes out
but like you're saying like how you know
you could take things and be a smuggler
and you can trade back and forth you can
do stuff like that in this or you can be
part of like you know the guard towers
which make sure that like one of the
neighboring towns don't attack you or
you could be a philosopher and you can
end up teaching your things you've
learned to other people or they could
teach you things or in or you could be a
scholar and just write all these
information down on books and you could
sell the books so it's got all these
aspects of the game it's really really
cool but I'll get you off off stream and
to all talk to you about that because I
can talk about it for hours because I'm
so involved in it and it's really really
interesting
so um yes anyhow uh why don't we tell
what did you tell everyone I just my
microphone why don't you go ahead and
tell everyone where we can find you your
times and your Twitter's and all that
fun stuff
sure so not too much so I am anchorman
v2 Xbox Playstation switch if they have
not allowed me to have enough characters
to put that as my title you can always
message me for my social security code
you want to play with me on switch
switch unless you want to get your get
your blank beat on smash bros by I think
we're Pokemon you know you find me also
same name bait everywhere that I try to
make sure I have that brand synergy
across a you know Instagram Twitter all
those you can find me on all those
places on that you can go to multiverse
show on YouTube they also have a Twitter
account also have an Instagram all that
we really use the Instagram you can go
check us out on there it's a lot of fun
like we do a show on Mondays at 8:00
p.m. Eastern like I said if you wanna go
check out that total dumpster fire of
Wow check it out on their likes if we'd
be the entire thing live every
everything was wheeled and dealed in
front of everybody else like there was
no background deal whatsoever it was
absolutely a blast to do and I loved we
get every year even though we all get
mad at each other and stop talking to
each other for about 48 hours that's
what friends do right
the only reason why we didn't do it was
because of the MLB the show getting
announced between Xbox
we were like way through the show
happens when you have arguments with
friends you don't talk for 24 hours and
then then you're fine again yeah it's
like really the some of the best guys on
there I'd do anything for them like they
really are excellent people so it sounds
good sounds good well I'm just gonna do
a couple of outros for
our friends here the or make it first of
all I would like to say on behalf of all
of us thank you very much anchorman for
coming and you know talking with us
today you brought a lot of insight from
from what you did and where you came
from and and I really appreciate you
taking the time out to do that so thank
you very much and I have fantastic time
I hope you did too
oh thank you for the invite man no
worries no worries we'll have you back
when when maybe the rest of the cast is
around we can etch that some more and
hopefully they got some questions after
they listen to the show and and that you
know what we'll get together again and
we'll end up doing this again maybe next
year sure sounds great so once again
l-boogie l-boogie oh 208 on Twitter on
mixer go check her out
old-school style he is old-school tech
talk on Twitter go check him out he also
has a YouTube page called old-school
tech talk about different types of you
know technology
I like your phones and what's coming up
new and great things like that MJ is a
boss check him out on Twitter he is
doing the college thing he's almost done
so hopefully he can be free and he can
be back on you know twitch playing his
games and check him out there it's very
easy for him to find and myself I am
Snell doe that's SN a ly do you can go
check me out on Twitter from Wednesday
to Friday at 7:00 to 10:00 unless I am
here sometimes I run a little later then
that's usually I'm usually up till about
11:00 and you can hit me up on Twitter
same name discord if you are part of the
iron Lords discord go check them out
it's fantastic like to thank all the
viewers and everybody for coming hanging
out and talking to us in chat I greatly
appreciate all the questions if anyone
has any questions for our guests please
check out round tables I should say
email us at round table stream team at
gmail.com we will try to ask our guests
those questions for you go check us out
on Twitter it is table stream I know
it's weird the right the long name
didn't fit go ahead and hit us up there
you'll see who our guest is I usually
try to get that done early and usually
give our time frames of what's going on
in there or if you have any questions
you can always hit me up directly
I say thank you to the iron Lords
podcast who is on on Sundays at 11:00
Eastern Time and check out Lords of
gaming dotnet for your gaming news those
guys are doing a fantastic job over
there myself an anchor are part of the
crew trying to do stuff for them there
and the iron let's podcast I think they
got two more weeks on Sunday and then
they're changing their times but go
check them out just so you guys know we
will be back on Monday next week we are
doing a just a group of us just
chit-chatting about the about the the
year and on what happens with us a
streaming life and all that jazz and
then after that we'll we'll probably be
seeing you guys next year but I'd really
appreciate if you guys come come back
again and check us out there thanks
again everyone have a fantastic a
fantastic week and remember everyone to
dream big and keep gaming and we'll see
everyone next week bye everybody
thank you